warum kann eine rakete ins weltall
fliegen wieso kann sich ein handy akku
wieder aufladen
und warum kann diese kamera ein video
von dem aufnehmen was ich hier gerade
mache diese fragen können wir dank der
physik beantworten naturgesetze sind die
regeln an die sich scheinbar alles in
diesem universum halten muss und diese
regeln stehen fest oder kann sich
wirklich nicht schneller bewegen als
photonen im vakuum wäre es möglich dass
ein objekt an mehreren orten
gleichzeitig ist und können gegenstände
teleportiert werden
heute geht es um ein thema das auf den
ersten blick keinen sinn ergibt
denn es widerspricht in jeglicher
hinsicht dem was die meisten von uns
unter den naturgesetzen dieses
universums verstehen und dabei ist es
genauso teil dieser gesetze wie die
gravitation die uns auf dem boden hält
heute und in den nächsten videos stelle
ich euch die schräge welt der quanten
vor
[Musik]
alles um euch herum die luft der bode
neuer bildschirm besteht aus dem was wir
materie nennen diese materie wie ihr
wahrscheinlich schon wisst setzt sich
aus atomen zusammen
große mengen an zusammenhängenden atomen
wie zb dein handy unterliegen den
physikalischen gesetzen die wir täglich
erleben
mit anderen worten ja dein handy wird
runterfallen wenn du es jetzt los lässt
diese wissenschaftliche theorie die
ideen rund um raum zeit und materie
werden auch klassische mechanik genannt
nun stell dir vor du würdest dich
schrumpfen nicht auf die größe einer
ameise nicht auf die eine sandkorn nicht
mal auf die größe eines bakteriums
sondern in den sub atomaren raum das
heißt so weit dass du kleiner wärs als
ein atom wäre das möglich dann würdest
du dich jetzt in einer umgebung befinden
in der alles was du über die
naturgesetze zu wissen glaubt kaum noch
gilt materie die man auf atomarer oder
super atomarer ebene betrachtet verhält
sich nämlich nicht mehr nach den regeln
der klassischen mechanik
hier regiert die quantenmechanik und sie
ist genauso verwirrend wie faszinierend
atome das heißt zumindest ihren look
leone also protonen und neutronen sind
nicht die fundamentalen bausteine
unserer materie
tatsächlich lassen sich diese millionen
nämlich noch weiter zerteilen
eine erkenntnis die experimentell im
cern nachgewiesen werden konnte
zum beispiel wissen wir jetzt dass ein
proton aus noch kleineren bestandteilen
den quarks und gluonen besteht aber das
ist heute für die grundlagen erstmal
nicht so wichtig stattdessen werden wir
uns die eigenschaften der
quantenmechanik die quanteneffekte
anhand eines elementarteilchen
veranschaulichen dass wir alle kennen
dem elektron wenn du dir einen atom
vorstellst dann mal so wir
wahrscheinlich einen kern aus um den
elektronen die kleine kugeln
herumschwirren
dieses modell wird ständig benutzt und
auch in schulen gelehrt und wir brauchen
solche modelle um komplexe phänomene in
der natur beschreiben zu können
nur ändern unsere modelle natürlich
nichts an der realität die natur ist nun
mal ein großes chaos und da sind die
elektronen keine ausnahme sie sind
nämlich alles andere als nur ein
teilchen das sich irgendwo im raum
befindet zumindest verhalten sie sich
nicht so eines der grundlegendsten
merkmale eines elektrons ist dass es
sowohl als teilchen aber auch als welle
agieren kann
diese eigenschaft wird auch welle
teilchen dualismus genannt aber wie soll
das gehen schließen sich diese beiden
eigenschaften nicht gegenseitig aus
genau diese frage stellten sich auch
viele wissenschaftler rund um den globus
es widerspricht nämlich allen bisherigen
erkenntnissen aus der klassischen
mechanik und trotzdem kann man genau
dieses verhalten mit hilfe eines
versuchs beobachten dem doppel spalt
experiment
der versuchsaufbau ist wie folgt eine
wand mit zwei eng beieinander liegenden
schlitzen wird mit quanten partikeln in
diesem fall elektronen beschossen
diese elektronik können dann entweder
durch die linke oder die rechte öffnung
hindurch fliegen und durch einen schirm
auf der anderen seite registriert werden
je nachdem an welcher stelle sie auch
kommen wird das auf dem schirm markiert
wären elektronen wirklich nur teilchen
dann würde man auf diesem schirm nach
einiger zeit zwei streifen erwarten auf
denen sich alle eingeschlagen den
elektronen ansammeln
logisch die elektronen die durch kommen
schlagen direkt hinter dem schlitz auf
dem schirm einen nur ist genau das nicht
der fall
stattdessen bilden sich auf dem schirm
ganz viele streifen es bildet sich ein
sogenanntes beugungsmuster ein phänomen
das man sonst nur von welden kennt ein
solches beugungsmuster kommt zustande
sobald zwei wellen miteinander
interagieren und sich entweder
gegenseitig ausgleichen oder verstärken
am besten kann man sich das mit einer
flüssigkeit vorstellen fällt etwas auf
einer ansonsten ruhige wasseroberfläche
dann bilden sich kreisförmige wellen um
den einschlag punkt gibt es jedoch zwei
einschlag punkte dann interagieren diese
welt miteinander und verstärken sich
oder löschen sich gegenseitig aus in der
fachsprache nennt man das interferenz
beweist dieses experiment aber nicht
einfach nur dass elektronen eigentlich
wellen sind und keine teilchen die wir
bisher annahmen
genau hier kommt der erste verwirrende
quanteneffekte ins spiel
aus der klassischen mechanik sind wir es
gewohnt dass wir alles erdenkliche
messen können wollen wir zum beispiel
die geschwindigkeit die größe und die
position eines asteroiden feststellen
dann könnten wir das wird mehr oder
weniger aufwand bewerkstelligen aber die
tatsächliche position oder energie eines
elektrons das ist nicht wirklich möglich
sobald wir erfolgreich die position
eines elektrons messen passiert etwas
seltsames es verhält sich plötzlich wie
ein ganz normales teilchen und verliert
seine wellen eigenschaft etwas was auch
als kollaps der wellenfunktion
bezeichnet wird
genau dieser quanteneffekte kann auch
wieder im doppel spalt experiment
beobachtet werden
nehmen wir einmal an dass wir an einem
der beiden schlitze eine messtechnik
anbringen
die uns benachrichtigt sobald sie ein
elektron wahrgenommen hat jetzt
beschließen wir diese schlitze wieder
mit teilchen welche zufällig entweder
rechts oder links durch den spalt
fliegen unsere messtechnik funktioniert
perfekt und benachrichtigt uns hin und
wieder das durch ihren schlitz ein
elektron geschossen wurde
müsste man jetzt eine aussage über das
muster auf dem schild treffen würden wir
wahrscheinlich alle behaupten dass wie
zuvor ein beugungsmuster zu sehen sein
wird
aber genau das passiert nicht durch den
mess prozess agieren die elektronen
plötzlich wie ganz normale teilchen und
der schöne zeit die entsprechenden zwei
streifen direkt hinter den spitzen
die elektroden haben durch die messung
ihre wellen eigenschaft verloren
oder anders gesagt die elektronen
scheinen zu wissen dass sie beobachtet
werden
aber haben wir nicht nur einen der
beiden schlitze überwacht müsste man
nicht bei elektronen die durch den
anderen spalt geflogen sind keine
veränderungen beobachten können nein
denn selbst wenn wir nur einen spalt
aktiv beobachten können wir theoretisch
durch das ausschlussprinzip rückschlüsse
auf den anderen spalt treffen
das ist eines der überraschendsten
phänomene der modernen wissenschaft weil
es unserer intuition komplett
widerspricht
selbst wenn wir etwas nur indirekt oder
sogar unabsichtlich messen lösen sich
quanteneffekte ins nichts auf ok
spannende objekte können also sowohl als
teilchen als auch als welle agieren in
der realität heißt das zum beispiel je
genauer wir die position eines elektrons
messen desto weniger entspricht diese
messung den quantenmechanischen
verhalten
na gut das ist jetzt vielleicht etwas
kompliziert ausgedrückt aber vielleicht
hilft euch ja diese animation die kugel
hier soll ein elektron darstellen da wir
es scharf sehen ist also genau messen
verhält es sich wie ein ganz normales
teilchen im raum lassen wir das bild
jetzt aber unscharf werden so dass
unsere messungen ungenau wird verhält
sich das teilchen plötzlich wieder wie
eine welle
dieses prinzip gilt auch für alle
anderen zustände von quanten partikeln
es ist als ob elektronen spüren könnten
dass sie beobachtet werden
quantenmechanik beschreibt waren sie das
verhalten von elementaren bausteinen
wenn wir nicht genau hinschauen und es
wird noch seltsamer denn aus irgendeinem
unerklärlichem grund scheint es so als
ob quanten partikel zwei gegensätzliche
zustände gleichzeitig annehmen können
ein elektron hat beispielsweise immer
einen gewissen sogenannten spin stark
vereinfacht reicht es wenn man sich
diesen spin eines teilchens als drehung
um die eigene achse vorstellt dieses
binden kann entweder in die eine oder in
die andere richtung zeigen was in der
physik als ab oder als downs bin
bezeichnet wird
tatsächlich könnte man eigentlich ein
ganzes video nur zum thema quanten spin
machen da wir aber in diesem video erst
mal das generelle konzept verstehen
wollen bleiben wir vorerst bei dieser
groben vereinfachungen die eigenschaft
des pins ist beispielsweise für atom
bindungen relevant wenn zwei atome eine
bindung eingehen wollen dann kann das
nur passieren wenn die zwei bindungs
elektronen einen unterschiedlichen
spinnen haben
das ganze ähnelt dem verhalten von zwei
magneten der pluspol ist immer zum -
polin gezogen und andersrum in unserer
ebene der realität in der welt der
klassischen mechanik wäre es völlig
schwachsinnig zu behaupten dass ich
etwas sowohl nach rechts als auch nach
links gleichzeitig dreht genau das kann
man aber wie soll es anders sein in der
welt der quanten beobachten
zumindest beinahe quanten objekte
befinden sich nämlich häufig in
sogenannten super positionen zwischen
zwei sich widersprechenden zuständen
befindet sich zum beispiel an elektronen
in einer spin super position dann gilt
die genaue richtung also ab oder down
als undefiniert es wird dann so als ob
das teilchen sich sowohl in die eine als
auch in die andere richtung dreht das
elektron befindet sich somit in einer
art dritten zustand der manchmal auch
einfach up down oder down und upstream
genannt wird
würde man so ein elektron genau messen
würde sich die super position in der
sekunde auflösen und das elektron würde
sich für eines in richtung entscheiden
man sagt das elektron kollabiert in
einen zustand
das konzept der super position gilt aber
auch für alle anderen eigenschaften
eines elektrons das teilchen könnte sich
so zum beispiel auch in einer räumlichen
super position befinden und somit an
mehreren orten gleichzeitig sein
das seltsamste an der quantenmechanik
habe ich aber noch gar nicht erwähnt
die sogenannte verschränkung zweier
elementarteilchen ein elektron kann
nämlich ein mit sich verbundenen partner
haben dieser quanteneffekte wurde schon
von albert einstein als gruseliges
ereignis in der ferne bezeichnet das
einem fundamentalen bestandteil seiner
relativitätstheorie zu widersprechen
schienen durch quantenmechanische
verschränkung wirkt es nämlich so als ob
information schneller als das licht
übertragen werden könnte grundsätzlich
versteht man unter der
quantenmechanische verschränkung eine
spezielle wechselwirkung zwischen zwei
elementaren teilchen auch hier spielt
der mess prozess wieder eine rolle wie
bereits erwähnt können wir durch den
spin eines elektrons eine messung
festlegen da sich so die super position
auflöst bei verschränkte elektronen
paaren konnte dann beobachtet werden
dass ein partner elektronen immer den
entgegengesetzten spin unseres ersten
elektro nissan namen müssen wir bei dem
einen teilchen zum beispiel ein ups bin
dann wird das andere elektronen sofort
einen downs bin annehmen und diese
verschränkung funktioniert scheinbar
völlig unabhängig davon ob es auf der
anderen seite des raumes oder der
anderen seite unseres universums ist
aber kommunizieren kann man auf diese
weise leider nicht das liegt unter
anderem am nur cloning theorem das
besagt dass quantenzustände nicht
kopiert werden können ohne die
ursprünglichen zustände zu zerstören
wir brauchen weiterhin einen klassischen
informationskanal quantenzuständen zu
kommunizieren
wir sind also nach wie vor an die
lichtgeschwindigkeit gebunden und
einstein behält wieder einmal recht
am ende der forschung sind wir aber noch
lange nicht und genau das macht die
quantenmechanik so spannend wie ich
finde wir leben zu einer zeit in der
noch lange nicht alle fragen beantwortet
sind und in dem wir noch mehr über uns
und unser universum herausfinden können
aus diesem grund produziere ich für das
bundesministerium für bildung und
forschung eine ganze serie von videos
die sich alle mit dem thema quanten
technologien beschäftigen
das hier war jetzt das allererste video
und sollte euch eine einführung in diese
verrückte welt der quanten geben
im nächsten video geht es dann darum wie
diese neuen erkenntnisse in unserer
technologie angewendet werden können bis
dahin bleibt neugierig
[Musik]